more than 20 years after the Civil War
and Bosnia and Herzegovina remains
deeply divided my guest this week is
Kjell Kurtz via Nova CH prime minister
of the country's Bosnian Serb entity the
Republic of Srpska
whose seat of government is here in the
city of Banja Luka for more than a year
the Bosnian Serbs have been threatening
secession non-cooperation even blockades
why are they choosing to play with fire
Kjell Catriona [ __ ]
welcome to conflict zone thank you it's
pleasure to talk to you every argument
here seems to become a crisis every
crisis is taken to the brink do you want
another war no of course we don't want
another war and there will be no another
war here you know we are not as I said
before a conflict zone you know conflict
of right to secede why the threats of
non-cooperation threats you know I mean
there is it there's a quite a good level
of cooperation I would say within
buildings are going about it just
depends how you view that you know and
what instruments you use to measure that
may last year president Miller as dodok
we sent a report to the UN
secretary-general he said the Republic
asepsis strong support for the ye use in
the new initiative we're implementing an
ambitious programme of reform okay
by June there was a row of an
anniversary he said something completely
different the reform agenda does not
exist for us I am the president of
Republic of Srpska and I represent it
and I give no consent for this whatever
some people may think 80 degrees you
know but it depends actually as I said
how you how you view these issues you
know of course that there is there is a
reform agenda you know it is defined so
what we hear no one actually did
something like that it is if it exists
definitely you know but then actually if
you work together all levels of
authority and bonding to the governor
trying to implement this reform agenda
there must be mutual respect with in
bosnia-herzegovina and we have to
understand each other and we have to
understand that we are working closely
and that we should be working closely in
implementing that how do we respect
excuse me now how do we respect somebody
who says one thing one minute and
something completely different that's
not change of attitude I would say you
know the reform agenda does not exist
for us that's what you say that's the
quilt you know it depends actually this
is just one element this is just one
sentence taken out of the context you
know actually that we are working very
hard
Lori castles got to fulfil our part
concerning the reform agenda and we
appreciate very much cooperation with
all other levels of authority in
bosnia-herzegovina and as you may know
there is a very good cooperation between
the two entities and I will say this is
the first time in Bosnia that we see
something like give you an another
example your president's letter to ban
ki-moon in May last year said Bosnia and
Herzegovina's Dayton structure is
indispensable to the stability and
functional governance required for EU
integration okay by December the first
all that had changed you threatened to
withdraw from all state institutions in
a hundred and twenty days if you didn't
get reforms that you were looking for
and your president went further he said
if we move in that direction we are
definitively going into a blockade of
Bosnia and Herzegovina and from that
blockade a breakup of the country is not
far away so one moment crow Zeiten is
indispensable and then you're
threatening to tear the whole thing up
it's wrong find differences there like
in different state that you talked to
president dodok actually so he could
really explain what he wanted to say and
Prime Minister you know of Republika
Srpska and of course that you are doing
very hard and we are trying to act
diligently in fulfilling oral conditions
but as I said there must be mutual
understanding in this country what the
issue was about what was the issue that
we are speaking now about what was the
issue what was the reason why he stated
that what was the problem that appeared
here in implementation of some of these
important issues so they must have in
some reason for stating something like
that you know
there's a reason before that you said
that everything is going swimmingly with
the other entities it's not my
understanding is that you're trying to
portray us as a bunch or group of rebels
in this country you know but I can tell
you that this is like a very stable
institutional setup speaking about
Republika Srpska
what we present is actually the views of
our institutions because we are
responsible to do that and as those are
like being in charge of many important
issues in Republika Srpska which is part
of Bosnia Covina we actually have any
right to say what we think about things
happening in Bosnia sorry that's not
true it's your misinterpretation of
taking it out from the context you know
and if there is reform agenda you can
say already it means that all of us have
to fulfill our tasks and you keep saying
to the international community if we
don't get what we want
there's a crisis to see you do this is
what you that if we if we move in that
direction we are definitively going into
a blockade of Bosnia it's blackmail
isn't it guess what we were there's no
need to block this country you know but
it was your president who said there is
no enough understanding with your
president who said it's not enough
understanding or what's really happening
in Bosnia Covina and what problems and
challenges it faces then sorry no one
has to do anything to block anything
because it will be cool you'll be fine
no you fine no we are fine great look at
your travel fine lastly last October you
had an agreement to discuss reform of
the Constitutional Court within the
structured dialogue
and your Justice Minister Anton Cassie
Povich said October the 15th progress
had been made he's hopeful a compromise
could be reached by December though we
have your president again saying
something completely different not only
should the Mandate of the court change
at all their previous decisions should
be live in the main subject maybe we
cannot rely on the international
community here maybe they are biased
your maybe I'm just raising this issue
no I'm sorry gee Tony to ask this you
know because there's no need to accuse
anyone I'm a citizen of this country I
know exactly what's happening in this
country I know exactly what the risk
fraud that we are facing in this country
I know exactly while the approach of the
international community has been towards
this area in the past 20 years there's
no one you know to give me lessons on
that because that bothers ago veena is
the failing project if you're suggesting
I didn't say okay hypothetically then I
would say if Bosnia Covina and it's a
failing project then I have to say that
actually both sides are guilty on both
sides are responsible so there is shared
responsibility for that when I say both
sides I mean domestic elements pass the
international community promise that
you've called a highly-charged
referendum about whether to go on
accepting the role of the state level
cause the referendum has been delayed
but the EU Commission said two months
ago your move runs against the written
commitment that you signed in February
last year and in July the ambassador's
of the EU came here to Banja Luka and
they said we are deeply concerned that
the proposed referendum would represent
an unconstitutional divide and weaken
those Authority but these are the
sentences that show that I know there I
trust I
I know that your eyes and these are
accurate selling political thriller but
please let's not cross the line into
fiction you know what I mean I'm saying
so words don't matter you say so
I mean you're quoting but why do you not
quote something like we you know we said
in this government but nobody was this
nobody wants this referendum and indeed
Serbia has told you your friends in
Serbia have told you they don't hold you
referee referendum is very compatible
with what we are trying to achieve
within the structured dialogue it is
very compatible because if it has the
same objectives and weakens those
authorities and would pose a direct
threat to the sovereignty and security
of the country as a whole because
whatever touches the lives of our
citizens can be subject of referendum
you know so it's very democratic you
know there is no threat you know
Republican okay Lucas obscure that we've
had from you just two months after your
commitment to carry out reforms in
preparation for EU membership you
actually threatened to secede from
Bosnia Herzegovina in 2018 April 25th
last year your party adopted a
resolution yet opposing referenda opted
by our political party a referendum on
full independence unless you get more or
too many full independence hmm not more
autonomy story-based this was the
referendum results your president said
that the Serb Republic authorities will
propose to the Federation in that
peaceful dissolution I think how could
you keep denying what's actually being
said in public you know which is a
mystery to me let me yeah I I see that
it's mystery you know but sorry I don't
have time to explain
not given this time you know so it's not
about seeking more autonomy it is about
trying to preserve the level of autonomy
that was given to Republika Srpska
within Dayton Agreement that's the only
thing which really matters here you know
we are not asking for something which we
have never been given we are not asking
for something new we just ask for all
the values and the principles of the
Dayton Agreement to be fully respected
and sorry I have to say that and I
regret very much that these basic values
and principles have been violated in the
past 20 years mainly by the
international community and that's our
view is very legitimate you know do you
want to join in the shape of the already
part of the international community
whether you like it or not I mean I
think it you think it comes with no
price attached you think you can
blackmail it's not blackmailing you know
it's wrong but sorry what is then wrong
we speaking now about efforts political
means economic and financial means
resources that have been used in this
country by the international community
using different methods of helping us
you know and still we can see that the
project is failing in accordance with
what many people think you know then not
because of Republika Srpska sorry it is
because of the methods which have been
obviously wrong or maybe not appropriate
you know you don't think if you stop
that you never speak about Bosnia but
you know what the problem is that this
country has never been treated
appropriately by outsiders you know ok
I'm not I'm not debating with you about
that you know I'm trying you just say
you have
you say you have initiated appropriate
speaking about methods that were
imported that have been used in this
country methods of for instance okay let
me give you just one example
hi representative and his activities and
you know that we can play the Dayton
Agreement that you support he's part of
an extended Dayton Agreement and he's
not final interpreter of date and of
course his final interpreter only of an
extent and he has very limited powers
according to an extent of the Dayton
Agreement you know it's quite clear if
you read carefully Dayton Agreement and
all its Alex's you will realize actually
that it is like that but that high
representative or high representatives
introduced the hundreds of pieces or
imposed let's say hundreds of pieces of
legislation in this country they change
many times you know present in this
country and of course there are rules
you have to that's quite clear
that's why activities in order to fulfil
these conditions step with the EU on so
many issues take foreign policy for
instance you fail to align with eleven
out of twenty nine Council resolutions
relating to foreign and security a
potential candidates country we are not
even a candidate country we are not
member of European Union we don't have
any obligation now at this moment to
fully comply you were to come by to do
that in the future but you know it
depends of course when we are going to
become member state it depends whether
there will be new member states given
the state you know your opinion
he's at now given the political will or
lack of political will towards new
enlargement and other things you know
but I'm you know and you are suggesting
now that bothers Segovia is fulfilling
something you know which bothers Davina
shouldn't be and it is not like you are
forced to do because we are just a
potential candidate country not even a
candidate country you said you are going
to ally or is the requirements of the EU
the EU is issued a list two months ago
of things that where you have to be
organized in UK will be detrimental to
European path of what the EU criticizes
you form one of the chief things it says
is corruption the political commitment
on corruption has not been translated
into concrete results here to combat
corruption it requires really a lot of
activities not only was there is the
governor but in all our countries here
in the region to develop proper
mechanisms to have enough of political
will but also enough cooperation from
our citizens you know the really to
struggle corruption but I will service
you are about we are very serious
because it is in the interest of
Republika Srpska T's injuring in the
interest of the other entity it is in
the interest of Bosnia as a whole
actually to develop very strong
mechanisms to combat corruption while
your police are accused of committing
crimes instead of actually solving them
you know six members of the special
police unit whoever is caught by police
force yes so they were discovered they
were like caught they were arrested by
the police means that the system is able
to act properly to identify the problems
to identify and locate perpetrators to
and then to catch them you think these
are the only six corrupt police officers
that you have do you think that this is
unique example in Republika Srpska it
doesn't exist in Federation does exist
in your country
very proud that our police system
discovered those who committed this you
know and that they arrested them I'm
very proud of that which means that the
system is able actually to act properly
and there is no segment of society where
you cannot find corrupt people whether
it is about the fact that two members of
parliament who actually belong to your
position bloc joined us and our two
members of parliament joined them sorry
then it's double crossed this alleged
conversation
why were they raided why were they
interrogated why were their computers
confiscated you know I'm just Prime
Minister I do not conduct such processes
you know and I do not have I learned it
from the media to be honest you know
because it here I mean you won't believe
that but I'm telling this is what about
that activity I learned from the media
and now there is another case in
bosnia-herzegovina you know that one
person who is a Bosniak leader of one of
the biggest political parties is
arrested how come that's something which
is court evidence is already like you
know transcripts of conversations and
other things telephone conversation is
already exploited by the media I mean
what are we speaking about it happens in
Survivor maybe we should that someone is
sorry you Commission two months ago says
the chances of exercising free speech in
this region have worsened last year the
political environment does not help
create the conditions for full freedom
of expression intimidation against
journalists continue what are the
obstacles actually for the development
of trepidation
India what what are the obstacles here I
don't see any formal obstacles for
having too much state control political
control over your state broadcaster rté
RS too much political control yeah of
course I can see that you picked up all
these elements you know I don't have any
political influence over the RT RS you
know this is part of it isn't it the
steering committee is politically
affiliated it increased political
control over the station and undermined
that system you know because you have
the same bodies in all three parts on
three elements of this joint
Broadcasting System
you know VIH TV you have Federation TV
you have our TRS here so is the same
rules and principles they operate you
know there is nothing new or different
here in Republic a success compared to
what we have at these other two levels
you know but how come that whenever we
speak about Bosnia Corvina how come that
we never speak about real security
threats we always speak about your
Republic as obscure about some allegedly
hidden agenda that it has with free
speech issues we're still delicious
your new public order law is causing a
lot of concern you criminalize posting
text symbols images or cartoons that are
obscene or offensive content that is
embarrassing or insulting that's the
area which needs working on definitely
yes you know but speaking about the
change that you are you passed at
Republic of Srpska law and speaking
about you're going to change whatever
actually proves to be bad or wrong are
you having to change that the question
you know any look simple question are
you gonna change that if there is a lot
of reasons
that's a lot of reasons to change that
you know but to practice sentences of up
to 30 days for disturbing social order
for insulting someone are you so
sensitive you politicians that you can't
be criticized or can be changed there's
a lot of enough evidence actually that
it requires it fails in practice and
shows a lot of deficits a lot of
shortcomings of course yes as I said
it's not Bible it's just a piece of
legislation that can be changed if there
is actually need to change that so the
practice will show it's not me to say
you now whether something is going to be
Cherica it doesn't depend on me it
depends on many elements as you I guess
know why did your president last year
describe Schreiber Anita which was the
site of genocide during the conflict why
did he describe is the greatest
deception of the 20th century probably
he had reasons actually to define it
that way I'm saying it wasn't genocide
there was a terrible terrible massive
crime committed in strabonitz officially
government and I think it was in 2006 or
in the beginning of 2007 actually passed
the decision at the government's meeting
you know to treat reverence as a place
of special interest which means actually
that massive investments would go there
and one of the first decisions of that
government was actually to send 50
million 5 0 50 million of convertible
marks actually to help development of
that area true in in that way of showing
actually demonstrating the approach of
the government of Republika Srpska
towards that area something that is
designed to open up a wound that
actually has never healed systemically
that's terrible that's terrible what
happened in severance a sterile look
happened in my reopen it
by calling it a greatest deception
there's no need to reopen that you know
reopen that what is important is
actually to show proper prose to
threaten it we can do it in many ways
one of the ways one of the proper ways
is actually to enable that area to
progress to support them financially to
support them economically to integrate
them within our development point which
we do as government of Republika Srpska
because you know that is the area which
will really deserve special attention
out of time out of time thank you very
much thank you
you